[Music]
so time then for the press preview from
cop 26 here in glasgow it's our first
look at what is on the front pages of
tomorrow morning's papers it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
paul mcnamee the editor of the big issue
and rachel watson the deputy political
editor of the scottish daily mail
they'll both be with us from now until
just before midnight of a good evening
to you thanks for joining us let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you then we're going to start with the
metro pledge to save earth's lungs reads
their front page as cop 26 world leaders
commit to reversing deforestation and
slashing methane emissions
well the times also talks cop 26 with
the headline pm hales deal to cut
methane emissions
here's the front of the ft confronting
corporate climate commitments their
headline banks under fire for diluting
green pledges since paris climate action
and the guardian says the heat waves and
wild fires of this summer would not have
happened without global warming
in other news the front of the telegraph
looks at the prime minister's plans to
replace the house of commons standards
watchdog
and richard madeley is announced as
piers morgan's replacement on good
morning britain in the sun with the
headline richard and susie
and i'm joined tonight by paul mcnamara
the editor of the big issue and also
rachel watson the deputy political
editor of the scottish daily mail great
to see you both so let's get cracking
shall we a very big day uh here in
glasgow um a a number of major
announcements the
uh metro uh puts it quite well i think
sort of encapsulates what's happened
today it has both the deforestation
announcement and also the methane uh
emissions um rachel
what have you made of today it's the
final day of the leaders summit do you
feel that these announcements are making
the impact that clearly the leaders here
want them to i think so i've been inside
cop for most of the day and i feel like
we're in a bit of a bubble actually in
here and i think these announcements
have been seen as quite optimistic we
heard from the prime minister earlier he
went back to his football analogy so he
had been talking about at the weekend
how we were five one down in this and
now he thinks we're maybe into extra
time now and he seemed to have a little
bit more optimism than he's had in the
previous week and because of these
announcements that have been made here
today and yesterday and we saw the first
minister today she spoke to a number of
scottish journalists and she seemed to
say and be speaking about the optimism
that she was feeling in the conference
whereas before everyone felt a bit
downhearted it didn't seem you know we
were coming to cop 26 with not you know
people were ambitious but they didn't
seem to have much hope of what was going
to happen here but you know the first
two days of the leaders being here
everyone is around there's a very kind
of optimistic and jovial atmosphere in
the building and but whether these are
going down as well outside the building
because when you look at the detail of
these announcements for example when you
look at the pledge to cut methane for
example that doesn't include russia and
china who are two of the biggest
emitters of this so i think you know yes
they look good and they sound good
sometimes when you see boris johnson
talking about them or joe biden talking
about them but actually when you look at
the detail of them and you talk to
people outside campaigners are they
going down as well as they are inside
this building and that's where we're
going to have to really look to see now
yeah when it comes to deforestation i
spoke to al gore earlier on tonight on
on sky news and he he reminded us that
in 2014 in new york there was a similar
commitment to uh really tackle uh
deforestation and actually nothing
happened in fact the worst thing
happened it actually uh did get worse
and uh and more deforestation happened
and that's the fear isn't it's all very
well having these great policy ideas but
we've got to follow through with action
do you think there will be action this
time on deforestation
well they say there's going to be but
then they've said that before and i
think as rachel said it's the absentees
that people are going to be looking up
both
china and russia but also because of
deforestation brazil are they going to
commit is bolstering is he going to be
the leader who's going to say right i'm
going to stop ripping apart the amazon
that really are the lungs of the world
and allow the regrowth there or is he
going to carry on because he doesn't
seem to
show much interest in any environmental
agenda so i i think
will anything happen you hope so
boris johnson is certainly buoyant but
then he's point about anything that he
decides he's going to be buoyant in that
moment
that doesn't mean anything's going to
happen i hope they do get somewhere
and
you know joe biden was saying today that
he believed that more had happened at
this conference than anything at any
other conference of this nature before
we just have to wait and see we we hope
and it does feel as though
outside uh in the wider media and the
wider world that there's much more focus
now on environmental issues
environmental questions it's no longer a
fringe thing for people who wear sandals
and grow their hair long this is
something that everybody
feels and wants to be part of but we
have to wait and see yeah let's slide in
uh the times front page they're focusing
on the methane announcement and one of
the problems rachel
is that it's it's a voluntary commitment
isn't it and how are we going to police
it and our u.s correspondent mark stone
show just how difficult that is even
somewhere like america in texas where
you know you can show that perhaps
people uh are allowing methane to go
into the atmosphere in quantities that
it shouldn't be but actually enforcing
it is really difficult
yeah this is gonna have to be something
that the government's and as i said
before we are here these announcements
are getting made they look very shiny
they look very great when you're at a
conference we all want to be talking
about climate change as paul said this
is something that everybody seems to be
interested in now you just have to look
the number of celebrities that are
turning up here for example this is
something have you seen him leo leonardo
dicaprio i did not see leonardo dicaprio
today i did see greta thunderberg though
so that was kind of you know you're
seeing some of the the big names that
are here and but i think when you look
at it now it's a bigger issue but it is
you know how will these governments go
back and how will they these play out in
their countries and how for example do
you get with me then you know the
agriculture sector fracking for example
two of the big issues with this in
america you know these are two huge
industries over there and how do you
sort that out and i think
it looks very good when you're here as i
said i think it looks you have cop in
these announcements and that's what
people want they want this they want the
hope they want optimism but actually at
the end of these two weeks
what's going to happen you know are we
going to look back in six months and say
that was a bit of a waste of time
because it just it filled the papers you
could talk about it on television it got
us some positive press for a little bit
but you know
places like russia and china aren't
taking it seriously potentially they're
not here and what does that say globally
for what people are going to
going to do and in their countries too
what kind of message does that send to
people there who run companies who run
businesses who are producing
methane and other um
fossil fuels or um gases what are they
you know what kind of message are we
sending to these people so i think
actually it's not about these two weeks
it's when we get past these two weeks
six months a year down the line what has
happened what's been achieved here yeah
and we'll we'll talk about um the story
that's on the the front of the telegraph
it's going to
feature heavily tomorrow the finance
implications and as as our science
editor earlier was talking about the
rewiring of the global financial system
because at the end of the day that is
that is a crucial part to all this isn't
it
it's absolutely fundamental and and i
think that mark carney talked a little
about this how much money is tied up the
vast amounts of money that are tied up
in particular funds with um
with different banks and with different
financial vehicles i'm trying to
encourage them to move into some area
that
looks at fossil fuel divestment that is
where it that is where we're really
going to get some impact um and rachel's
right you know when it's at governmental
level and they go back to their nations
and
big
beef producers in particular nations say
well we're not really into this we need
to keep our industry going
if there are financial houses behind
them saying no hold on you're not going
to get the investment to do that
unless you follow our particular plan
that's when i think we will we will see
the difference there was a protest today
um in the middle of glasgow by extension
rebellion they cut off one of the main
streets war lou street for quite a
number of hours they were campaigning
outside one of the uh the american
investment banks jp morgan because of
this very thing they said they're not
divesting quickly enough from fossil
fuels and i think
that may be where the the focus will
move
quickly from now follow the money that's
where we'll get the result yeah it was
interesting hearing boris johnson wasn't
in his in his final news conference in
fact speaking to our political editor
talking about our personal
responsibility as well and we need to
walk away from those companies from
those banks that don't do what we feel
they should be doing when it comes to
the climate you know we have a role in
that as well and we'll just finish
before the break with the uh the front
of the ftse their headline banks under
fire for diluting pledges and again it
goes back to what you were saying before
you know it's all very well making that
place but you've got to follow through
yeah and i think this is another area
like we were talking about the telegraph
front page where we've got to take
people with us you know the government
has to take people with with them on
this and how do they do that how do they
look at businesses banks and make sure
that they are doing what they say
they're going to do and doing what they
need to be doing in this fight you know
this is something we've heard from
everyone this affects everybody on the
planet and as we said just now everybody
is interested in this everybody has a
role to play in it and there is that
personal responsibility there is that
responsibility from business but it's up
to the government to ensure that they're
taking everyone with them as well and
that people realize that responsibility
and act on it as well yeah just before
um
we head to the break uh want to get your
thoughts on president biden uh
criticizing china saying it's a big
mistake for for president xi and
president putin not to be here
is that a bit of an own goal do you
think has he made a mistake there
perhaps not being more diplomatic
because uh they won't like that will
they be criticized
well like that the channel will always
play the long game anyway and i don't
think it's really going to put their
nose out of joint they i'd guess they
know they should have been here but do
they care enough i i don't think that
they'll be terribly upset by what joe
biden says and they're pushing ahead
there was a story this morning that
because of an energy crisis in china at
the moment they're ramping up um mining
of coal so they can produce more energy
in that way so they're they they're just
going ahead with what they want to do
anyway i don't think biden had you know
it was a diplomatic gaffe he was saying
if we're serious about this everybody
has to be serious yeah they've announced
the opening of uh more than 14 coal
fired power stations this year alone
haven't they um yeah quick thought on
this rachel from you yeah i think the
same as paul i think you know there's
countries here that there's countries
that are not here that know that they
should have been here they say we heard
from boris johnson earlier that it was
coveted as the reason that they're not
here but whether that is the case or not
you know this would have been a very
difficult conference for
countries like russia and china to send
their leaders to and i think you know
that will have been in the back of their
minds as well as covert and it is
something um you know that we've heard
from the leaders on today yeah the prime
minister being more diplomatic i think
than the president is fair to say thank
you both very much indeed stay with us
coming up after this short break uh
something to whine about yeah wine might
not be as good for you i'm afraid the
scientists originally thought talk about
that and plenty more in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
welcome back to glasgow you're watching
the press preview uh paul and rachel
still with me uh the front page of the
mirror um this is a a very worrying
headline 60 000 carers face sack over
jabs uh carers have been told that they
could lose their jobs if they refuse to
have the vaccine and um i mean
the uh
care system is already in crisis this is
really going to push it over the edge
well
if it does happen i mean i'm i'm
surprised that 60 000 staff have refused
jobs at all considering how at risk
enough for an awful lot of people
particularly the elderly who were taken
from hospitals and put into care homes
really without um any checks that
people who work with them are prepared
to risk their health by not having the
job in the first place so that the
number is quite staggering really to
begin with and then i suppose we boil it
down and see whether that is actually
the case but if it is and it is 60 000
people who will be pushed out of that
industry that is a crisis for the
industry yeah according to this uh the
article in the in the mirror um 105 000
vacant posts already
yeah and this is one of the areas that
we are seeing a crisis in staffing and
we're seeing in a number of uh sectors
across the uk and in scotland i mean
this story actually brings in scotland
there's not been any threats of any
nature from the scottish government on
uh
social care having to be social care
workers have to be double jabbed but we
have heard from care home workers and
bosses who said they have rewritten
contracts to ensure that everybody who
now starts with them is fully vaccinated
before they start so we've already seen
moves within the sector to ensure that
their their staff are
vaccinated their
residents are fully
are the people they go out to
are
safe from kobe and that they have that
extra protection from those looking
after them and i think it is a
conversation that a lot of people are
having should people who are working
with vulnerable people be fully
vaccinated but when we're facing such a
crisis in our social care and health
care system does feel like there needs
to be a better way to solve this than to
get rid of them yeah okay agree more uh
inside the mirror and we'll just finish
on this story i've been clinging on paul
to that bit of research from many years
ago that a glass of wine a night is good
for you now they're saying it might not
be
well quite a few of us have been
clinging on to that and it's not just
one class and that you know um and it is
getting late and it's getting close to
that time i've read this story twice
and the headline certainly says that
that isn't good to you and i haven't had
any yet but i can't quite make sense of
the final two paragraphs to work out
whether been totally
abstaining is the best thing to do or to
have a little bit more because it seems
to suggest
that both ways you're you're pretty dumb
as we all are well well that's quite an
optimistic note to to to finish on
rachel very quick thought on this from
you yeah it was the same as paul it was
one of those stories that when you you
read it your first
instinct is oh
that's
oh no basically is the answer to that
but i think when you start to read
through it the details there and the
differences between those who are t
total and those who maybe have one a
night and actually
it's probably the same because it says
people who are tea total usually have a
reason to quit drinking alcohol and
that's how they've made that comparison
in the story yeah and that research has
yeah do you like it
maybe not every night every night not
when i'm on the television
until midnight
um thank you both very much